- Tell your friends at home that Geno does deliver!
- So what I like to do is I gel and then blow dry.
- Ooh.
- Oh, interesting.
- Hey, bet, say less fellow young coaches.
Uh, hey, Kliff, where's Kyler?
- Uhhh…
- See, I prefer to play this game
because it's harder to intercept the grenade.
Oh, wait. I gotta go.
Take my playbook, not my console!
Damn, fam, Imma be late as hell.
Football and gaming combined together…
Ugh, this is like homework.
Oh, hell, yeah, a power-up.
Oh, not cool, fam.
Uh oh, it's the Fighting Brothers game.
- You know, I'm sick of our parents
wearing half your jersey and half mine.
- [All:] There can only be one brother!
- Go left, Mac-Man...go, uh, right Mac-Man! Uh, right!
- Oh, Coach is gonna be hella mad.
- First DeAndre, now Kyler. Whatever are we going to do?
- Everyone, calm down. I coached Mahomes in college.
- Phew, that's right.
- Browns, you piece of s--t gang.
Stop kicking me! Ow. Why are the Browns the one f--king team to make a kick this weekend? Ow!
- Please let me out. I'll limit my screen time!
- Yeah, of course I tried blowing on it. See?
- I'm back, fam.
- You, uh, missed the Chiefs game.